in a seaside village of Novartis in the
Philippines Erik harami Yano has been
behaving erratically for months people
here believe that his soul is under
siege by none other than the devil
himself
the Philippines is home to over 60
million Catholics for most Filipinos
their concept of evil is based on the
Christian belief in the devil Eric's
mother Elena her Ammiano fears for her
son's soul every night she reads the
Bible and prays for him often that's
when the trouble starts tonight a
reading from Scripture triggers
something in Erik his handshake his eyes
roll back in his head whenever he has an
attack his reaction changes his eyes
become vicious he shakes some things
sometimes I'm afraid Elena believes evil
has descended upon her son he claims not
to remember what happens during his
attacks by Catholic tradition only
priests can conduct exorcisms but one of
manila's most famous exorcists is a
former Catholic who offers his services
for free he'll see hundreds of patients
in a day they called him ha among
convinced that evil spirits possess her
son
Elena seeks help from Kyle among to
purge the spirit The Exorcist must first
identify it
cheating us we'll try to find out who's
possessing you okay he places feathers
between Eric's toes in a belief that
they will invoke the spirit Satan is
just one possible source of the evil in
Eric before Filipinos adopted
Christianity they believed in a whole
host of evil spirits to this day demons
evil dwarves and trolls are blamed for a
variety of maladies
but the exorcist suspects that this time
the devil himself is involved i wanna
battle shouting about that he thought
one during the first time this boy
visible immediately knew this wasn't an
ordinary case possession i touched the
feet with he fell to shiver I knew it
was a bad one car among tries to
communicate with the spirit may I get
your weather don't you get it
whoever you are I just want to speak
with you my hos up what I wanna think I
wish you no harm
to the Exorcist it appears that the
spirit has seized control he demands
answers why are you in the child oh go
ahead speak what is the reason this is
something you need from him in a state
of possession eric begins to scribble
it's a disturbing message garbled words
about darkness and the devil for two
days just go to church so that your
prayer comes from your heart two days
have passed Eric and Alayna returned to
the exorcists kah among begins again by
placing the feathers between Eric's toes
he tries to contact the spirit Hey does
that hurt nothing kah Eamon finds
nothing wrong he believes the powerful
combination of the earlier exorcism and
Elena's prayers have vanquished the evil
spirit they won't come back it's over
you've gotten through it Elena is
relieved Eric seems better but to be
sure she seeks further guidance from her
priest father Rik has performed nine
exorcism sanctioned by the church but
he's skeptical whether Eric was really
possessed within minutes the priest
uncovers another possible reason Eric's
father died several months ago and Eric
only heard about it three months later
the attack started around the same time
father Rik suspects Eric has been
suffering from psychological trauma the
priest thinks the exorcism might have
made the attacks worse by convincing
Eric that his spirit was to blame
but kah among still believes he saved
the boy he says the church disapproves
of his work because he's not a priest
unless outside we go what can I say to
people that's happy in their age a
double let's say this is taboo you don't
find it I'm finding out that is your
opinion he got got a deleted I honor and
respect you you know I'm only doing this
to help you but dude it was a diode as
long as thousands of people in Manila
continued to believe in his powers
Kyle Iman will continue to battle evil
spirits free of charge